EVEN WITH SOME OF THE GOOD STUFF
THAT IS IN THIS BILL.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION IS
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN MARK
IMMEDIATE OS CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS, AND A
DEMOCRAT FROM ILLINOIS, GREAT TO
SEE BOTH YOU.
LET'S START WITH YOU,
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS.
I DELIVERED SOME TOUGH MEDICINE,
BUT THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO DO.
WHEN I LOOK AT THIS LEGISLATION,
I CALL IT LEGISLATION, BUT IT'S
MORE THAN -- THERE IT IS.
I THINK THIS IS NOT DRAINING THE
SWAMP.
WHO'S ACTUALLY READING THIS,
CONGRESSMAN?
WHO HAS READ THIS ENTIRE BILL
TONIGHT?
>> I CAN TELL YOU, NO ONE'S READ
THE ENTIRE BILL, SOME 2,230
PAGES THAT WE GOT OVER A LITTLE
OVER AN HOUR AGO.
I'M ABOUT 200 PAGES INTO IT.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE STAFF GOING
THROUGH IT.
BUT REALLY, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
DRAINING THE SWAMP.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL, WERE YOU TOO HARSH?
THE ANSWER IS, NO, YOU COULD BE
A LOT HARSHER.
WE CONTINUE TO FUND SANCTUARY
CITIES.
WE CONTINUE TO FUND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
WE DON'T BUILD THE WALL, BUT WE
PUT MONEY IN FOR A TUNNEL.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS
CAMPAIGNING, HE WASN'T
CAMPAIGNING FOR A TUNNEL BETWEEN
NEW JERSEY AND NEW YORK.
IT WAS FOR A SOUTHERN BORDER
WALL.
WE'RE STILL GOING THROUGH THIS.
BUT I'M NOT VERY OPTIMISTIC
THERE WILL BE CONSERVATIVE WINS
IN THIS.
>> CONGRESSMAN MURPHY, IF I'M A
DEMOCRAT AND I SEE THE HOUSE IS
IN REPUBLICAN HANDS, THE
SENATE'S IN REPUBLICAN HANDS, WE
HAVE A REPUBLICAN, A
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN LIKE
DONALD TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND I SEE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
FUNDED, SANCTUARY CITIES FUNDED,
CHUCK SCHUMER GETS HIS MEGA
TUNNEL, NEW JERSEY-NEW YORK, AND
A BUNCH OF OTHER STUFF GETS
FUNDED, THERE'S NOT A BUNCH TO
GET EXCITED ABOUT.
YOUR REACTION?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
SUPPORTIVE ON A LOT OF SHARED
PRIORITIES.
IT FUNDS MILITARY AND DOMESTIC
PROGRAMS, ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE OPIOID CRISIS WHICH IS
RAVAGING OUR DISTRICT.
AND THEN IT HELPS TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR NIH AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE OUR VETERANS ARE
TAKEN CARE OF.
I HAVEN'T READ THE WHOLE BILL,
AS MARK MENTIONED, BUT I'M
OPTIMISTIC.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN COME TO
A COMPROMISE BY TOMORROW.
>> Laura: NOW, YOU HAVEN'T READ
THE BILL AND I'M NOT CRITICIZING
YOU BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE --
THE EVELYN WOOD A-PLUS CITATION
STUDENT COULDN'T READ THIS BILL,
OKAY?
I'M NOT CRITICIZING YOU, BECAUSE
YOU JUST GOT THIS.
BUT GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT OUR
CURRENT DEBT LEVELS, IT'S
EXPLODING, EXPLODED UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA, EXPLODED UNDER
BUSH, NOW IT'S SET TO INCREASE,
COULD BE ANOTHER $1 TRILLION,
MARK, TELL ME IF I'M WRONG ABOUT
THIS.
DON'T WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO BE HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GETTING
THE MONEY TO FUND ALL THESE
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES, CHINA,
JAPAN, GERMANY, ALL THE PEOPLE
WE'RE BORROWING IT FROM?
WE DON'T HAVE THIS MONEY, DO WE?
>> NO, WE DON'T.
LAURA, HERE'S ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS.
YES, WE'LL END UP WITH A $1
TRILLION DEFICIT THAT WILL
PROBABLY COME OUT IN OCTOBER OF
THIS YEAR, $1 TRILLION-PLUS.
HERE'S THE OTHER INTERESTING
THING, YOU DON'T HAVE TO READ
THE FINE PRINT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GROW THE
SIZE OF GOVERNMENT BY 12% TO
13%.
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT KIND
OF GROWTH, I DON'T KNOW THAT HIS
DISTRICT OR MY DISTRICT, ANYBODY
BACK HOME SAW A 13% INCREASE IN
THEIR WAGES BUT SOMEHOW WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE GOVERNMENT A RAISE
LIKE THAT?
HERE'S THE OTHER PROBLEM, LAURA,
IS THIS.
WE HAVE A REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED
HOUSE.
SENATE.
AND WE HAVE A REPUBLICAN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND WE HAVE A DEMOCRAT HERE
TONIGHT SAYING HOW GREAT THIS
BILL IS.
THERE IS A PROBLEM THERE WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT.
>> I THINK THE RIGHT HONORABLE
GENTLEMAN FROM NORTH CAROLINA --
>> Laura: HE'S SMILING.
CONGRESSMAN, FIRST OF ALL, I
ALREADY LIKE YOU, BECAUSE YOU
CAME ON THE SHOW.
A LOT OF YOUR COLLEAGUES WON'T.
BUT I ALREADY LIKE YOU, BECAUSE
YOU'RE BEING HONEST.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL FOR
DEMOCRATS.
IT'S GOOD THE MILITARY GETS TONS
OF FUNDING AND THAT'S ALL GREAT.
MILITARY NEEDS A RAISE, I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT YOU'RE SMILING, NOT JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE HANGING OUT WITH
US ON WHATEVER THE HECK THIS IS,
A WEDNESDAY NIGHT, YOU'RE HAVING
FUN.
THIS IS A GOOD DEAL GOR
DEMOCRATS, I'M SORRY.
>> HOW CAN YOU NOT SMILE WHEN
YOU'RE STANDING NEXT TO
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS.
LOOK, I HAVEN'T READ THE FULL
BILL, I HAVEN'T MADE MY FINAL
DECISION ON THIS, BUT IF IT'S
FULLY FUNDING THE MILITARY
PROGRAMS, RIGHT NOW OR MILITARY
READINESS IS AT ALL-TIME LOWS.
SECRETARY MATIS SAID WE CANNOT
GOOD ON ANOTHER CONTINUING
RESOLUTION STOP-GAP BUDGET.
IT WOULD HURT THE MILITARY.
>> Laura: MAYBE WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THAT THE NEXT TIME WE
COMMIT OUR TROOPS TO SOME
GODFORSAKEN COUNTRY.
MAYBE WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT WHAT
IT WILL COST WHEN WE COMMIT OUR
TROOPS TO ANOTHER MULTIPLE